[Applauso]
il nuovo docente è proprio colui il
quale si mette in gioco il mio metodo è
giocare seriamente
ho scoperto che anche giocando si può
imparare l'anno comprovato un sistema
che funziona tantissimo prima di tutto
perché se mi diverto io si possono
divertire anche loro la felicità
contamina quindi il nuovo docente
capovolto e il colore il quale si mette
in gioco prima di tutto ma dobbiamo
essere consapevoli noi mondo adulto del
valore dello spessore del nostro ruolo
che non è soltanto quello di fare e
trasmettere informazioni ma di essere
quello che è uno specchio di rimando per
il mondo dei nostri ragazzi
le nuove indicazioni nazionali ci dicono
molto
il ministero ha redatto proprio queste
indicazioni partendo dai bisogni dei
nostri ragazzi
punto focale del nuovo modo di essere
docenti partire dalle loro competenze ed
abilità trampolino di lancio per il
mondo del lavoro
che cosa significa questo significa che
il nuovo docente ribaltato capovolto non
è quello più dietro una lavagna davanti
a una lavagna o dietro una cattedra o
che dice studia da pagina 31 35 non può
essere più dobbiamo essere al passo con
i tempi seguirli e sarà al loro fianco
essere consapevoli del cambiamento ma il
cambiamento da che parte possiamo
partire dai bambini delle partite dal
mondo adulto che deve essere lo specchio
dove loro si riflettono vedere un adulto
lagnoso triste che cosa produce nei
ragazzi sconforto i bambini arrivano in
classe e sono già ansiogeni perché il
mondo adulto che cosa fa e tutto in
corsa c'è un tempo che non è un tempo
buono e felice ma arrivano già
catapultati da un finestrino in classe
con le ansie di prestazione dei genitori
mi raccomando
quando guarda quello più bravo di te mi
raccomando l'ansia della prestazione
quindi la mattina ci uniamo e facciamo
circle tanto ognuno parla delle proprie
esperienze delle proprie paure delle
proprie angosce e insieme cerchiamo di
ribaltare la situazione
quello che per gli altri è un ostacolo
io l'ho ribalto insieme a loro eccomi la
triste perché mi annoiavo le recite
penso alla nostra collegano di prima
penso che andrea ha tutto un filo
conduttore che ci lega a tutti quanti
per la passione la felicità contamina
appunto quindi il nuovo docente è colui
il quale si mette in gioco
fondamentalmente è un mondo adulto che
ribalta la sua visione che si mette in
gioco con i ragazzi perché io imparo da
loro e loro imparano da me questo metodo
non è nient'altro che la passione e
messa in campo tutte le esperienze che
diventano il gioco forza di un
ribaltamento della lezione quello che
per gli altri era un ostacolo io insegno
in una scuola dentro un parco una delle
poche scuole rimaste in italia dove
abbiamo uno spazio bellissimo si parla
tanto di educazione finlandese ma noi
abbiamo questa grandissima opportunità
abbiamo piccole casette ogni casetta
contiene massimo tre classi ho cambiato
scuola quest'anno sono arrivata in
questa zona di roma centrale
fortunatissimi perché stiamo sopra la
basilica di san paolo e nessuno voleva
andare insieme ai grandi perché i miei
colleghi oi genitori diciamo no i tuoi
piccoli di seconda elementare che cosa
fanno impareranno le parolacce e brutte
cose si picchieranno come fanno a
giocare con i grandi
abbiamo ribaltato la situazione ho detto
sì sì io voglio andare lì abbiamo
inventato lezioni di tutoraggio dove i
ragazzi grandi insegnano i piccoli come
vedete dalla foto non vedono l'ora di
incontrarsi a ricreazione non vogliono
più giocare con quelli della loro età
ben si vogliono rimanere a giocare con i
grandi dove imparano e dove i grandi si
sentono responsabili dove anche il
ragazzo quello un po spavaldo si
tranquillizza perché ha un ruolo e
perché il piccolo
ho visto finalmente quindi questa unione
forza grande e piccolo è il ribaltamento
della nostra visione che cosa significa
tg scuola tg scuola è una di quelle
esperienze che ha portato un grande
successo dove i ragazzi diventano da
veri e propri giornalisti che aveva
paura del foglio bianco cominciò a
scrivere parla di se stesso anche una
riga ma non importa
era quello che andavamo alla scuola che
tutti dicevano ma no murdoch e che farà
da grande ha imparato a scrivere a ha
cominciato a parlare ai ragazzi sono
stati valutati da una commissione hanno
visto che l'anno scorso il ciclo che ho
lasciato all'esame di terza media al
liceo alla licenza di terza media hanno
superato l'esame con il massimo dei voti
perché perché un acquisito autonomia
consapevolezza delle loro capacità
abilità appunto perché sapevano esporre
con grande forza e non avevano paura di
sentire la loro voce potevano parlare
davanti a tutti perché grazie al tg
scuola ogni mattina noi scegliamo un
argomento e diventa l'articolo del
giorno c'è chi fa il cameraman
c'è chi fa il la colonna sonora
ognuno grazie al gioco forza delle
proprie visioni le mettiamo in campo per
avere una visione unica di insieme e
come regista che ha bisogno di diverse
telecamere per produrre quello che sarà
il suo filmato il suo documentario la
mia visione è diversa da quella mia
insieme leoniano un'altra esperienza
formativa e il cocktail learning appunto
dove ognuno mette in campo un aiuto
verso l'altro maestra non ho capito
questo non c'è bisogno che io dia la
risposta
la risposta è dentro di te le nuove
indicazioni nazionali partono proprio da
questo creare il loro una forza una
consapevolezza sulle loro capacità
creando un pensiero logico critico e
creativo
perché la creatività è il punto di
partenza che non può morire e il gioco è
lo stimolo lavoro di squadra e leggo
sono una grandissima forza quando
eravamo piccoli jolly usavamo adesso
sono ritornati in auge lo story telling
perché lasciare il passato per andare
direttamente al papa al futuro
troviamo un ponte e il truck e il nostro
punto di forza
passato e presente le uniamo per andare
verso il futuro
l'orto didattico un'altra esperienza
perché sono le esperienze che fanno e
portano a fare per imparare i nonni sono
diventati il nostro punto di forza
i nonni che insegnano i più piccoli a
che cosa significa seminare e piantare
raccogliere per poi andare a vendere i
prodotti e il ricavato comprare del
materiale di facile consumo per la
scuola che cosa si fa
tutte le materie in trasversale
verticale sdraiati in piedi come volete
ogni esperienza diventa materia di
insegnamento non c'è più un programma
come facciamo a spiegarlo ai genitori
ansiogeni quaderno bianco
siamo andati all'orto ma abbiamo fatto
matematica abbiamo fatto classificazione
semi piante frutti siamo andati al
supermercato ad acquistare abbiamo usato
la moneta hanno saputo raccoglie
prendere il resto perché preoccuparsi di
un programma esistono adesso classi
laboratori esperienziali dove fare
esperienza nel benessere a tutto campo
è questa la nostra visione dei docenti
innovativi gemellaggio di alle francia
una grande scommessa
nessuno voleva investire su questo tutti
avevano paura ma la forza quale è stata
quella di conoscere una preside a parigi
ci siamo uniti abbiamo iniziato dai
disegni da mandarci delle lettere dopo
di che era troppo forte
l'intento di rincontrarsi loro sono
venuti da noi ospiti dalle nostre
famiglie che cosa abbiamo fatto
abbattuto i costi perché abbiamo speso
sotto solo il biglietto di viaggio
dopodiché anche senza parlare la stessa
lingua
riuscivano a comunicare attraverso che
cosa il gioco giocando mettendosi a
confronto hanno acquisito autonomia di
pensiero problem solving abbiamo visto
che le classi che partivano in
tutoraggio perché classi miste dalla
scuola elementare primaria di 8 anni
fino alle medie sempre in tutoraggio
grandi e piccoli
abbiamo visto che hanno una marcia in
più si nota la differenza sono più
reattivi
nel trovare soluzioni a tutto campo
alleanze a scuola e famiglia
fondamentale non se ne può fare a meno
non siamo due mondi distanti ma siamo
bina su un binario unico
all'inizio dell'anno creiamo un patto di
alleanza dove insieme
focalizziamo gli obiettivi e bisogni
obiettivi e bisogni visti dalla famiglia
visti dalla scuola ma per dare il meglio
ai nostri ragazzi senza l'alleanza sul
territorio senza l'alleanza delle
istituzioni non potremmo sopperire a
quelle che sono le mancanze sia
strutturali sia materiali perché
purtroppo non possiamo farne a meno di
notare che la società è un ottimo in
difficoltà e la scuola è una di quelle
istituzioni che soffre gravemente della
situazione e grazie all'aiuto di
istituzioni privati di sistemi di
socializzazione di associazioni di
protezione civile è fatta dei nonni
possiamo realizzare tutte le cose belle
per poter far fare esperienze ragazzi
global di share prize che devo dire è un
lampo a ciel sereno
non me l'aspettavo l'otto dicembre
arrivata una telefonata che mi diceva ma
lei non legge ma le mail con fi ma noi
siamo quelli del globe asti chart price
ma io le vedevo e l'eccessivo pensavo
fosse spam
dice no no lei arrivata tra i 50
migliori insegnanti 38 mila candidati in
tutto il mondo che io da quel mondo
da quel momento la mia vita è cambiata
sento sulle spalle la grande
responsabilità
io lì in mezzo tra loro in tutto il
mondo e tutti che parliamo la stessa
lingua
ma non perché parliamo l'inglese ma
parliamo la stessa lingua emotiva che
parte dal cuore testa e cuore uniti
perché felici di fare quello che
facciamo
la barclay fondation voluta da sani var
clean il fondatore ha unito tutti i più
grandi magnati unendo tutte le grandi
risorse materiali investendo nella
scuola la scuola come punto di partenza
per il miglioramento della società
partendo dalla cultura qualcuno che
crede che partendo dalla scuola qualcosa
può cambiare questi loro non li
prendiamo cuccioli per poi farli
diventare quelli che saranno uomini e
donne nel mondo del lavoro
quindi il ruolo del docente di noi
adulti
lo vedo non come una un ruolo visionario
ma rivoluzionario rivoluzionario che
significa non più appunto da pagina 30
35 studia ma qualcuno che mondo ha
dovuto investe e si mette in gioco per
essere trampolino di lancio in quello
che saranno le nuove professioni
inventarsi nuove modalità per creare
nuove forme di lavoro per credere in
percorsi alternativi da offrire a loro
io credo nella creazione di una zattera
fatta ad ognuno di noi dove l'importante
è essere uniti verso lo stesso scopo
quello di creare benessere e creare
opportunità di lavoro nel migliorare nel
migliorare la visione di un mondo
questa zattera unita ci può portare
perché ognuno investe nelle proprie
capacità abilità come proprio quello che
dice la scuola questa zattera che forse
può far risorgere questa nostra italia
bella come ho visto bella brescia che
non conoscevo fatta di cultura di storia
perché dobbiamo far emergere le cose
belle che abbiamo in italia perché noi
facciamo sempre due passi indietro
pensando che gli altri sono molto meglio
di noi ma noi italiani abbiamo un
percorso storico pedagogico che forse
qualcuno dimentica maria montessori
tutti lo sappiamo da maria montessori
partano molte attività didattiche degli
altri paesi stranieri
quindi il valore noi ce l'abbiamo come
storia cultura
quindi noi come non visionari ma
rivoluzionari di un trampolino di lancio
per quelli che saranno uomini e donne
nel mondo di lavoro e io posso dire si
può fare come il film celebre che tutti
conosciamo di mel brooks si può fare
partendo dal cuore e dalla mente
[Applauso]